let's get into this big news ladies and  gentlemen we've got the Twitter thread  from Barry Weiss the Twitter files part  two Twitter secret blacklists I Will Not  Waste Your Time Dr J batachara charya  was arguing that covid lockdowns would  harm children he was placed on a Trends  Blacklist and also has this flag recent  abuse strike whatever that means then we  have Dan bongino who was search  blacklisted and he also had something  called a notification Spike I don't know  what that means you can see he had no  strikes but they put him on a blacklist  that look and and it says multiple  accounts Twitter blue verified not safe  for work view I wonder what spma means  Charlie Kirk do not amplify recent abuse  strike and notification Spike multiple  accounts not safe for work view  interesting